hi my name is Thomas Stuber from the
Film Academy badenwürtenberg in Germany
my film of dogs
horses
R and W I alone
verses have to say what I have to do I
want to try it Schifer Buy your
newspaper Sportwelt you will find everything
you need to know Statistics Formkurve
knows that  Horse the jockey and make
sure you have an outsider in it
otherwise you won't get good odds and
always tell yourself in the next race I'll get
the big money if it wasn't the last
race of the day
you want to go tomorrow
how much do you want to
risk  350 for the whole next
month my chances are zero
if you don't come along not everyone
on the outside are losers Rolf and if you
like the name Lilli or Jess willwin
then nim Rolf Beginners often have the
greatest luckol that's all that matters
you can tell
the winner from the startol  you can tell right from the start you
trollo
[music]
[applause]
B
[music]